okay so if we're doing this technique
it's right here
my body and
I'm just happening to his
okay so his energy is going that way I'm
not gonna pull him back I'm gonna let
him go forward and I curve this
okay
you're doing that intention Noggin not
with the hand on his neck but you're
doing it with this hand right here okay
so this hand has to make that same Loop
in his body
[Music]
that means
his head is going to go forward
and around and then back and then out
and that's my pattern there he's going
to go forward
around and out okay
so I'm doing it with this house I'm not
going to touch him let me touch your
face I'm not gonna touch his face here
and then crank it over with some
imaginary mechanical advantage
I'm gonna make his Center move okay oh
make his Center move whoa
cool
it is I always show
without the throat he was already
falling that way hence I say I'm aiming
falling bodies
so now you take him again
you can do it this way you're going to
do the same exact thing it's just like
didn't you knock it but it's this side
so I move him around oh
[Music]
thank you
not his head hitting and pull out
you take his Center you move your Center
move his head around
if you take off that arm
boom here it is again can you see
cool
same thing
move his Center
got the idea
okay try
okay so some differences here
here you made contact
pay attention no contact he's moving
around
do you get that
I don't know is that a good angle
maybe try over here
so you're doing you're doing what
shinsuke did you're hitting
and then you're
you're watching no contact
he's already falling backwards
it's not my arm goes forward
and then I do it
Center boom
okay
okay do you get that that's a cue you
can use okay all I'm doing is is my
final rotating I'm working at that
energetic alchemical level okay that's
all I'm doing
the same pattern every single time just
sometimes you do one side sometimes you
do both sides okay but it's the same
pattern every time all throughout key
one wasn't all right try it again when I
say that I don't try to throw him that I
just do this
that's that that's why this would feel
wrong
even if you even if you got it
[Music]
I only felt that
you see that I just felt a curve going
in I didn't feel the whole thing do you
understand okay
so it doesn't matter the next point it
doesn't matter that I'm on this arm and
I'm doing that way
to me it doesn't matter because I'm
always doing the same thing internally
out chemically okay so it doesn't matter
that we come over here do you understand
and you're here like this like he was
okay it doesn't matter
where do I do that rotation it's not
on that part
it's right here so I ignore the other
arm and I move him around
so I don't want you to get confused on
that's not the exact person it doesn't
matter to me okay so you couldn't do the
exact version you're over here and you
go over here and I move that around
because I
because that's what I'm moving
no I don't I don't do anything ever but
if I was
myself
I just feel me
okay all right try
okay so if I look to somebody on the
outside that's why I always say only UK
can really tell uh what's going on uh
but on the outside it looks like you're
just uh why would that be an energetic
alchemical do
you okay
um you're I just think you're just
rotating your hips or your your stomach
or something do you get it but uh the
Tom Den is only formed that's the
remember that in Aikido everyone says
you have a tanden you don't have a Tanta
and you form the tandem the tandem has
to have that young energy come in you
see and meet the yin energy coming back
up and then then the ton deadness warm
it's not for you don't have it
anatomically okay so uh for for example
so uh we're here and uh you again push
push your hardest you see it this is
what he feels okay and he doesn't he
feels that exact same thing throughout
the entire technique okay so uh let's
let us uh I'll show that we have the the
connection already okay it's not that
you are gonna fall forward like uh so
I'll have you pull pull backwards all
right do you get it he's gonna pull
backwards and you're gonna make it move
do you see hey
[Music]
and here I am
if you pay attention
maybe there
okay
you you uh push into me so he's pushing
this way now you say it's not doing
anything okay go forward
keep safe and so when you see me
bringing him around he doesn't feel like
I got out of the way and he fell
he he feels that that his whole Center
I'm gonna exaggerate if this isn't the
keyhole but I'll I do is full Center
that whole
that hole okay uh so as as we're moving
it looks like I'm just getting out of
the way like TCA but you know you can
tell no some something else is going on
here okay so that's this is what you're
feeling you see hey and then uh what I
bring you here you're gonna feel the
same thing so here I it's off here on
all right you see
then I keep the time then through your
young energy
I keep the tandan and I rotate that
feeling
okay do you get that can you see that
now he's not just
falling in and there's going his his
whole body is moving
okay
okay this part is moving okay
all right give it a shot
do you feel that
all right
so your your whole body is not that I've
been here crank you down then
you have the whole body
okay you know
like if you were in another art right if
I was in the other Arc
you press but we're not we're at this
start so I work
I work this
you're here
see Chris
thanks
there's my new IP point
and I keep working the same feeling
that's off
on in the center I move my Center her
Center moves turn
okay stay where you are there you go
okay uh let's uh try to go forward
[Music]
try to come in come into me
is he trying to go out
you see there's only one way to go
that's where we're going
it's got it
do the other one
I want you to turn anywhere you want to
get the hell out of the technique
and that is exactly where they turn for
their front brake pump
okay